en varias ciudades de eeuu
los manifestantes se tomaron las calles
indignados su ira dirigida a la corte
suprema- tras la filtración del borrador
de una opinión que sugería que el órgano
judicial estaría a punto de anular el
fallo histórico de roe versus wade de
1973 que estableció el aborto como un
derecho constitucional da miedo es
devastador pero definitivamente estoy
motivada para seguir luchando y nos
aseguraremos de que el acceso al aborto
permanezca no se trata solo del aborto
se trata del control y ahora estamos
viendo que el control se nos va y no lo
toleramos mientras estos manifestantes
luchan para que se mantengan los
derechos de las mujeres a decidir
algunos estados ya se están preparando
para una nueva era si se anulara el
fallo histórico el derecho a interrumpir
el embarazo se dejaría en manos de los
legisladores estatales y los líderes de
estados conservadores ya están listos
para convocar a sesiones legislativas
especiales para prohibir el
procedimiento si el tribunal supremo
revoca la sentencia el gobernador de
oklahoma firmó un proyecto de ley que
prohíbe el aborto después de seis
semanas coincidiendo con una ley similar
en texas gobernadores demócratas en
estados como california anunciaron
rápidamente planes para consagrar el
derecho al aborto en la ley local un
movimiento alentado por el presidente
joe bites en su administración pide a la
corte suprema que proteja el acceso al
aborto
como se atreven a decirle a una mujer lo
que puede y no puede hacer con su propio
cuerpo como se atreven a tratar de
evitar que determine su propio futuro
como se atreven a negar a las mujeres
sus derechos y libertades
el borrador no es una sentencia
definitiva por lo tanto no es seguro que
se revierta la histórica decisión a
pesar de una mayoría conservadora en la
corte suprema- una encuesta del
washington post y el vice news encontró
que sólo el 28 por ciento de los
estadounidenses cree que la decisión de
1973 debería ser anulada